[Carl Ide:] In the public interest, the Westinghouse Broadcasting Company
and the University of Pittsburgh, one of the
nation's major health centers,
in cooperation with the American Medical Society and the United States Public Health Service,
bring you "The Silent Invader," an up-to-the-minute
report on Asian influenza.
[Dr. Carl Ide:] How do you do? I'm Carl Ide.
Throughout history, mankind has been forced
to wage many battles in order to protect
his family or nation against misfortune, disaster,
or even possible extinction.
Now sometimes these wars have been...well
they've been catastrophic.
There was the catastrophe of 1918 when an
influenza epidemic
swept through our own nation as well as the
entire world.
Unlike the battles of nation-against-nation,
or humanity against the forces of nature,
when man has often had an opportunity to prepare himself,
the battles against disease throughout the
centuries have often found man
in the unfortunate position of having to combat this
enemy only after it had infiltrated
his community and infected much of the population.
Recently, you've become aware of a pandemic
or a worldwide epidemic,
which originated in the Far East and is now
known as Asian influenza.
Because of the alertness and efficiency of
the United States Public Health Service,
and the World Health Organization, a detection
system similar to that of the aircraft spotting
has been established throughout the world
and has enabled us to recognize
and follow the progress of Asian influenza as it circles the globe.
Health authorities expect an outbreak this
fall and winter in the United States.
But not in such portions as in the 1918 epidemic.
Now the man upon whose shoulders rests the
responsibility for preparing the United States
for the impending battle with Asian influenza, is Dr. Leroy E. Burney,
Surgeon General of the United States Public
Health Service.
Dr. Burney, I imagine you and your staff have been gathering
quite a tremendous amount of material on Asian flu.
Now it seems to me that everybody I know has
had and has talked about influenza.
But I don't think anyone really knows what
it is.
[Dr. Leroy E. Burney:] Well, Carl it's a,
one of the upper respiratory infections,
something like a cold, only it's caused by
a flu virus.
And the difference between the Asian influenza
and the influenza that we've been having
all of these past few years is that this strain began in, the strain of the virus
began in Hong Kong and spread from Hong Kong to the rest of the world including the United States.
[Carl Ide:] Mm-hm.
Well, every year influenza is a problem in
our communities.
I'm sure it is in yours, too.
Why are we suddenly so all concerned about
it now?
[Dr. Leroy E. Burney:] Well, that's a very
good question.
We are concerned because in the other countries
in which it's appeared, and even in the outbreaks
that we've had so far in this country, the
attack rate has been 15 to 20 percent of the population.
And this attack rate occurs in about four
to six weeks.
For example, in metropolitan Pittsburgh, with
approximately one million people,
if we had this flu strike here, you would
have approximately 200,000 people
who would become ill in a four-to-six weeks' period.
And this, of course, would make a tremendous impact upon the economy of this particular area.
[Carl Ide:] That's understandable.
Well, we've all heard of outbreaks here in
this country Dr. Burney, uh, exactly how far has it spread?
[Dr. Leroy E. Burney:] Well, it's spread all
over the United States.
The first cases occurred, surprisingly enough, on the East Coast rather than on the West Coast,
among Navy personnel at Newport, Rhode Island.
And then the second group occurred a few days later
in both Navy and civilian personnel in San Diego.
Since that time, of course, which was about
the first of June, it has spread in localized outbreaks
through Grinnell, Iowa, to the Boy Scout
Jamboree in Pennsylvania, to Louisiana,
and to actually almost all of the states in
the United States.
[Carl Ide:] I didn't realize that actually
that was Asian flu that hit that Jamboree in our own state. It was Asian flu?
Dr. Leroy E. Burney:] That's right, it was.
[Carl Ide:] Well, from what I've been able
to learn, Dr. Burney, not many people
have died as a result
of Asian influenza in the rest of the world.
Now do you think the same will hold true here
in the United States?
[Dr. Leroy E. Burney:] We have the belief,
now based upon the experience
of Asian influenza in the other countries,
in South America at the present time, where
it is in epidemic proportions,
and as a result of the outbreaks in this country
so far, that it is a mild infection,
and with a very low mortality rate.
And we believe that it will continue to be
both a mild infection and have a very low death rate.
[Carl Ide:] Well, is there the possibility
that Asian flu might turn into,
if I may use the word, a killer?
[Dr. Leroy E. Burney:] Well, that is a possibility, of course,
and that has happened in preceding years when we have had epidemics.
Back in 1888, when we had a large epidemic, and then many of us recall the 1918-19 epidemic,
when we had a mild influenza epidemic
in the spring of 1918.
And then in the fall we had a large outbreak
of very virulent influenza,
followed by serious complications.
And then another wave hit us in the February
or March of 1919.
At that time, as you may recall, in that
whole period, we had about 20 million cases
in the United States, and about 850,000 deaths.
But I would like to add that conditions are
quite different now than they were then.
In the first place, we have a mild strain
of influenza, not a virulent strain.
In the second place, we have the antibiotics
to combat any complications that might arise,
which we did not have in 1918.
[Carl Ide:] Mm-hm.
Well doctor, with the disease spreading so
rapidly,
what exactly now are we doing to combat it?
[Dr. Leroy E. Burney:] Well actually Carl,
we are doing, trying to do three things.
One is to develop as rapidly as possible the
only preventive agent that we have
against influenza, and that is the vaccine against this particular strain of the vaccine, of the virus...
and that is being done in six of the large
pharmaceutical manufacturers of this country.
The strain was collected by an alert U.S. Army medical team in Tokyo,
and sent back to this country, and then given to the U.S. Public Health Service.
We distribute it to the manufacturers, and
they, in turn, actually began to manufacture the vaccine
before we had had the first case in this country.
So now our job is to get more of that vaccine
available, and to get the public to use it.
Number two, we have to be prepared to take
care of the individuals who become ill.
And we have been working since early June
with the American Medical Association,
the American Hospital Association, state and
territorial health officers, voluntary groups,
and others,
to prepare for taking care of those who become
ill.
And finally, the matter of having an alert
and an informed public,
one who will be aware of the facts without
being unduly alarmed.
And certainly this program of the Westinghouse
Broadcast Company is a good example
of public service to have an alert, but not an alarmed public.
[Carl Ide:] Well Dr. Burney, you and your
public health service crew, if I can use that word, crew,
have certainly seemed to make great strides in order to
get us ready for this possible epidemic in
such a very short time.
[Dr. Leroy E. Burney:] Well, we've had a lot
of help, I can assure you Carl, in doing this.
It hasn't been a one-man or a one-organization
show.
As I said previously, we have had the full
cooperation and support of the
American Medical Association
in both the educational, as well as the medical
care part.
And then in working with the manufacturers to get them to manufacture the vaccine
and to stop other activities and to build up their staffs.
I think we can all be proud of the industry
which we have in this country.
It's another example of the know-how and the
expeditious way in which free enterprise,
through our American industry, can do a good
job.
The vaccine, or the virus, was given to the
industries about the middle of May,
and within three months, vaccine was being released through our National Institutes of Health,
as being both a safe and an effective vaccine.
And that seems to me a good example of both teamwork
and a very expeditious work by the manufacturers.
[Carl Ide:] Mm-hm.
[Dr. Leroy E. Burney:] Another example of
this teamwork, and to illustrate that this
isn't a one-man show is that we have with us this evening, I'd like to present to you, Dr. James A. Crabtree,
who's Associate Dean of the University of
Pittsburgh Graduate School of Public Health
who will discuss how Asian influenza has spread
throughout the world.
[Carl Ide:] Well, thank you very much, Dr.
Burney, and I'm awfully glad
that Dr. Crabtree is here with us tonight, too.
How do you do, Dr. Crabtree?
We've been discussing the fact that this Asian flu has covered a lot of territory in a short time
But I would like to know how did it all get started?
[Dr. James A. Crabtree:] Well, the exact point
of origin of the influenza virus
is of course not known.
But the current epidemic had its beginning,
as Dr. Burney indicated, in Hong Kong and Singapore.
Uhh, this was in early April.
By mid-April the disease had become indeed
epidemic in both of these cities
and remained so throughout the rest of the
month.
From Hong Kong and Singapore, the disease
rapidly, in early May,
moved to the island of Formosa.
And here, it's estimated that as many as a
half million people
were attacked within a relatively short time.
From Formosa, also during the month of May,
the disease next made its appearance in Borneo and Japan.
And from the major shipping centers, from
these several areas, the disease very rapidly
scattered into widely, such widely separated places as Malaya, Indochina, Indonesia,
India, Guam, and the Philippines.
The first cases...also in late May, the disease
was reported as far away as Australia,
and on board several ships en route from Australia to San Francisco.
The first appearance of the disease in the
United States was on June 2nd.
This date is important because ahh, it means
only a short six weeks from the time
the first cases were reported in China, they occurred in the United States.
This indicates the great rapidity with which
influenza and influenza-like diseases
can spread over the world.
By mid-June, this disease had practically
circled the globe, including southeast Asia,
southwest Asia, the Middle East,
Europe, Australia, and North America.
Late in June, the disease made its appearance
in North Africa, introduced probably
by the Moslems returning from their pilgrimage, pilgrimages to Mecca.
So that finally in late July, in early July,
the disease made its appearance in Chile,
in South America.
So that in three short months, every continent
on the globe had been involved
in this great pandemic.
[Carl Ide:] Well Dr. Crabtree, you mentioned
that it had been reported on ships en route
to San Francisco, and that several cases were definitely diagnosed,
among our fleet at Newport, Rhode Island.
Now wouldn't it have been comparatively simple to have isolated these known cases
and prevented the spreading of them, and kept them from coming in at all?
[Dr. James A. Crabtree:] Unfortunately, not
so simple.
For the reason that quarantine against influenza
is not effective.
Had it been possible for all of the cases
on board these ships to have been isolated,
it would have had little effect on the actual
spread of the disease because undoubtedly there were
many more people on board these same ships, who by reason of a more recently acquired infection,
would have shown no symptoms whatever
of the disease, and therefore,
they could not have been readily identified if they were passing through a quarantine station.
[Carl Ide:] I see.
Well, Dr. Burney had mentioned that we had
approximately
25,000 known cases in this nation.
Are they all bunched in one area of the United
States?
Or has the virus spread all over?
[Dr. James A. Crabtree:] The virus has spread
all over.
We have some maps here in the studio that
the television audience can see,
which graphically shows how the disease has
spread in the United States,
starting from Newport, Rhode Island and the West Coast.
During the month of June, the disease had
spread to Salt Lake City, Utah;
to Grinnell, Iowa;
Cleveland, Ohio; and a few cases along the
East Coast.
If we could have the map from showing the
spread in July, we see that the disease,
starting from these original centers, has literally moved in practically every direction throughout the country.
Then the final map sort of speaks for itself
in that it indicates that this virus has become
very well-seeded in practically every state
in the country, certainly in every major region
of the country.
[Carl Ide:] Well, I think I've got a pretty
good idea of how influenza spreads, Dr. Crabtree.
But I'm still wondering about the virus itself.
Uh, what kind of an animal is it?
[Dr. Leroy E. Burney:] Well Carl, I'd like to present to you one of our staff from the National Institutes of Health
of the Public Health Service, Dr.
Dorland Davis, who is the Associate Director
of our National Institute of Allergy and Infectious Diseases, and ask him to answer this question
and any other scientific questions that you
might have.
[Carl Ide:] Well fine.
Thank you again, Dr. Burney.
Dr. Davis, it's awfully nice to have you
take your time and come see us tonight.
I'm going to ask what is probably going to
seem like a silly question.
But I'd like to know what is this virus like?
What is this virus?
[Dr. Dorland Davis:] Well, to begin with Carl,
influenza is a specific disease
caused by a specific virus.
This virus was first isolated back in 1931
by Dr. Shope at the Rockefeller Institute.
And then subsequently in 1933, it was shown
to cause human disease by British scientists.
[Carl Ide:] Mm-hm.
[Dr. Dorland Davis:] Now we know that there are three major classifications of virus.
Types A, B, and C.
And more recently a new type, a fourth type,
D, has been described in Japan.
[Carl Ide:] Mm-hm.
Mm-hm.
Well this A, B, C, and D, is this fourth type,
the D Type,
is that the Asian flu?
[Dr. Dorland Davis:] No. No.
[Carl Ide:] You said something about it being
related to Type A.
That's what confuses me, the A, B,and C [chuckles].
[Dr. Dorland Davis:] No.
The Type A influenza is the influenza
which commonly causes epidemics and pandemics
at intervals throughout the recent years.
[Carl Ide:] Mm-hm.
Mm-hm.
[Dr. Dorland Davis:] Now the Asian-type of
virus is a Type A, and it causes the kind
of disease which we have had in recent years.
[Carl Ide:] Mm-hm.
[Dr. Dorland Davis:] So, now the, however,
the antigenic composition of this Asian type
is different from that which we have described
in the more recent strains.
So that a person who is immune to the older strains is probably not immune to this new strain.
And thus the vaccines which have been developed
in the recent years by Drs Francis, Salk,
and others,
have no, probably no effect on this invader from Asia.
[Carl Ide:] Well, I guess this is one of the
reasons I'd never get into medical school.
[Chuckles]
So a new vaccine has to be made each time a new strain comes along.
That is correct, is it?
[Dr. Dorland Davis:] Yes.
[Carl Ide:] I mean that explains why we don't have this vaccine in stock, the live vaccine in stock.
That is right.
[Carl Ide:] Well, I think everybody's hearing
a good deal about the Asian flu story,
but will a person know if he has Asian flu?
If so, how?
[Dr. Dorland Davis:] Well, I think he will know.
Sometimes his physician finds it a little
difficult to diagnosis it because the symptoms, may be,
are similar to those caused by other respiratory viruses or actually, respiratory bacteria.
So that, to be absolutely certain, we must
use laboratory methods
to make a specific diagnosis.
Now these are generally of two kinds.
One is the actual isolation of the virus.
Or the second is the demonstration of antibodies
which appear in the blood of the person who,
while he has the disease.
Now this often takes a little time,
and it really doesn't help the patient's position very much,
but it is important for us to know what kind
of disease is prevalent in the community,
and to discover what the type is and follow its course.
[Carl Ide:] I see.
Well naturally, the thing most people are
concerned about is the vaccine, first of all,
and particularly how it works in the system.
Now it seems to me that, being made from real
Asian influenza virus,
wouldn't there be some danger in being vaccinated?
[Dr. Dorland Davis:] No.
There's no danger at all.
The vaccine is completely killed during the
process of being prepared.
[Carl Ide:] Mm-hm.
[Dr. Dorland Davis:] Now the vaccine is made by injecting this virus
into fertile chicken eggs where the virus grows.
And then by processing the fluids, the vaccine
is made by the manufacturers.
It requires about forty days to manufacture and to test this vaccine.
[Carl Ide:] I see.
Well Dr. Burney, I can breathe a lot easier
knowing a little about how this vaccine is made
and that there isn't any live virus in it, and I'm certainly impressed with the way
your public health team operates.
I mentioned it before,
I want to impress that on you for our viewers
as well as myself.
[Dr. Leroy E. Burney:] Thank you.
[Carl Ide:] Up to now, I think that you've
given me and the rest of the audience
a complete picture of the Asian flu.
[Dr. Leroy E. Burney:] Well, I rather doubt,
Carl, that we've given you a complete picture,
because we've left out one of the most important
groups of our total team
in meeting the challenge of this new Asian
influenza,
and that is the American Medical Association,
which represents
the physicians throughout our entire country.
We have worked with them from the beginning
of this and have had complete support
and understanding from that group.
And I would like to present to you here now,
the Secretary-General Manager of the
American Medical Association, Dr. George Lowe.
[Carl Ide:] Thank you again Doctor.
Dr. Lowe.
[Dr. George Lowe:] Mr. Ide.
[Carl Ide:] It's a pleasure to have you coming
here tonight, too.
I believe your home port would be Chicago?
[Dr. George Lowe:] That's right.
[Carl Ide:] Well, Dr. Lowe, can you explain
a little further about this possible flu epidemic?
[Dr. George Lowe:] Well, in planning for a
possible flu epidemic,
the medical profession has three responsibilities.
Keeping the doctors informed on the progress of the disease, spearheading the mobilization
of all medical personnel who will be concerned with the caring for the sick, and informing the public
on what to do once the virus has struck.
The doctors are being informed about Asian
influenza through our weekly journal,
and through many scientific periodicals published
by the various states and county medical societies.
They are being encouraged to cooperate with
the Public Health Service in detecting
the presence of the virus and its spread from community to community.
They're being provided with late reports on
the technical aspects of the disease
and with instructions regarding the administration of the vaccine.
The American Medical Association has asked every local medical society to organize
a committee of those who would be involved in an epidemic so that an agreement can be
reached in advance on such matters as vaccine
priority, the handling of transients,
hospital admission procedures, and so forth.
And if an epidemic does strike, the medical
professions will use every means of communication
possible--pamphlets, newspapers, radio, and television--to tell the general public what to do.
It is important, we feel, that families know
the symptoms of the disease and the basic points
to follow in home care of the flu victim.
[Carl Ide:] Well, what are those symptoms,
Dr. Lowe?
[Dr. George Lowe:] Well, the Asian influenza's characterized by a rapid onset high fever,
often as high as 104 degrees, headache, sore throat, aching muscles, and extreme weakness.
The recognition of symptoms, of course, is
important early in an epidemic.
Once the Asian flu takes hold in a community, why, you'll know what it is
without checking the symptoms.
[Carl Ide:] Well, when you do get Asian flu,
Doctor, how do you care for it at home?
[Dr. George Lowe:] Well ideally, your doctor
should be called, and his instructions followed.
However, in an epidemic situation, he may
not be able to give your case his complete attention.
In that event, these are things to remember:
First, keep away from others.
Second, go to bed.
Third, drink a lot of fluids.
Water and fruit juices.
And fourth, if your doctor recommends it,
take a fever-reducing agent.
And fifth, call your doctor if any unusual
symptoms develop.
[Carl Ide:] What do you mean by unusual symptoms?
[Dr. George Lowe:] Well, primarily those that
would indicate the onset of some lung involvement,
a heavy cough, rapid breathing, blueness of
the lips.
[Carl Ide:] I see.
Well thank you very much, Dr. Lowe.
And now I'm going to ask Dr. Burney if he
would summarize our discussion.
[Dr. Leroy E. Burney:] This fall and winter
we may see serious outbreaks of influenza
in the United States as a consequence of the epidemics which began last April in the Far East.
Unlike similar instances in the past however,
we believe that the size and severity
of the epidemics can in this, be minimized
in this country.
Thus, it is the opinion of experts that there
is no need for hysteria or panic.
The influenza is concerned...in the first
place, we are prepared for the invasion.
And in the second place, we now have the means
through a new vaccine
to help prevent this influenza.
Perhaps the story of infection by influenza
virus can best be summarized in this manner:
There is a pandemic, a worldwide epidemic, of Asian influenza,
which has attacked most of the nations of the world.
Laboratory tests have shown that it definitely
has reached the United States,
attacking both military and civilian personnel.
The virus causing this influenza has been
isolated and recognized as a member
of the familiar type of "A" virus.
An effective and safe vaccine has been developed
as a preventative, and currently is in production
by six pharmaceutical houses in this country.
At the present time, Asian influenza can best be classified as a mild, virus disease
which attacks many people, but has a very
low death rate.
Experts say that it is probable that an epidemic
will occur in this nation
sometime between late fall and early winter.
For the first time in history, a nation, our
own United States, is in the fortunate position
of being ahead of an impending epidemic, and thus has had the time to organize
for an all-out offensive against Asian influenza.
There is always the possibility of an increase
in virulence of the infection
as the epidemic increases.
However, the new vaccine has been proven effective in control studies conducted
by the military and should be an excellent weapon to combat the disease if the epidemic progresses.
When the vaccine is made available for public
use, the Public Health Service
and the American Medical Association hope
that the nation as a whole will participate
in a voluntary program of vaccination against
the prevalence of this influenza.
Rest assured that there is no need for alarm,
panic, or hysteria.
If there is a change in the situation, you
will be informed immediately
through the public education channels of your American Medical Association, United States Public Health Service,
and state and territorial health officers.
This program, by the way, which is a result
of the combined efforts of organized medicine,
private industry, and education is an excellent
example of the type of public information
and education we are setting up.
In closing, I would like to urge you to make
use of the new vaccine when it becomes available,
knowing meanwhile that you will cooperate
with the medical profession and the public health authorities
if it becomes necessary to set up priorities for those groups responsible for public welfare
and safety and who must continue their
important services if others of us
are temporarily incapacitated by Asian influenza.
[Carl Ide:] Well Dr. Burney, I'm sure I speak
for all who have been with us during this program
when I say how much we appreciate all of you gentlemen taking your valuable time to come here
so that we might be better informed on Asian flu and what is being done about it.
Participants on tonight's show have been Dr. Leroy E. Burney,
Surgeon General of the United States Public Health Service;
Dr. James A. Crabtree, Associate Dean of the University of Pittsburgh Graduate School of Public Health;
Dr. Dorland J. Davis, Associate Director in
Charge of Research
of the National Institute of Allergy and Infectious Diseases, United States Public Health Service;
Dr. George F. Lowe, Secretary and General
Manager of the American Medical Association.
"The Silent Invader" was written by Tom Coleman.
Produced by Roger Wolfe.
Directed by Jack Simon.
Script research by Rose Marie Scarpiello and  Kay McDonough.
"The Silent Invader" has been brought to you as a public service
by the Westinghouse Broadcasting Company
in cooperation with the American Medical Association,
the Public Health Service of the U.S. Department of Health, Education and Welfare,
and the University of Pittsburgh Health Center.